welcome to this video while this is
Maradona again I get to play this girl's
guy really often and he has gotten in
some wins laser getting in some wins her
lately I really need to stop that most
of the winds worm when I really played
stupid stuff out of good positions so
got a king zinian Kings Indian with
night bd7 Bishop e3 I think you go to
see one here right yeah how does wide
play this not sure about it probably you
can play with a quick before not sure
about the precise move or as here now
you can play hmm I don't know
he might he might play a five at some
point or play with 66 in case of c6 I
have Bishop a 3 now this was my idea
that seemed with night on d7 and on f7
he doesn't really have much pressure on
my center which is good so it should be
pretty or should I just feel [ __ ] oh
it's not a bad idea he doesn't
pressurize my center so i am not really
forced to play d5 I don't have to now
know it takes oh this is nice now it was
just good for my disposition let's see
Queen d2 just centralized completely or
anything else that's it's good I might
he might have Bishop h6 sent but I could
have gone to could have gone to see to
maybe ok in any case it seems that he
tries to play a form
Bishop on b2 is indeed a little bit
questionable this is such a great piece
okay i'm going to turn prepare before in
case of a for I have beef on
okay preparing to play f3 not sure this
is such a great idea actually have three
I sometimes bishop age six maybe I had a
three and before as was what's the basic
alternative but it also opens up them
the a file okay now yes move this away
this might gain and strength a little
bit there's a 3 B for business
and this night on c5 this is only really
active p so it's probably something that
i should fight with before ah now he's
moving the rock back and now yeah before
looks kind of normal but not sure night
a form at the end so kind of annoying
move quince it to was something that
that makes some sense but you might have
f5 getting everything opened maybe night
f4 then is good difficult okay I can
play this pin strengthening move don't
think he has anything great anyway
nighty for rookie for
now so I'm it's not winning material
here and here I wanted to do this I'm
one f5 so that it's not a move that you
can play I'm covering d for now safely
and I'm ready for before that's very
nice now I'm getting coordination now
the coordination that I need to push him
away with before okay dad that's not
really nice yeah okay see five is good
for white I can also just take my one
down
not necessary to do immediately it sets
it's good for wide width with many moves
actually even this kind of pinning
slowish the pool approach is quite good
going for c5a taking f6 the only thing
that he might have is rookie to win I
have to be very about that but it's not
a big deal 96 is the threat at the
moment so he cannot play rugae to anyway
Bishop c4 it's just good for wide right
it's a big pin
Queen f7 b7 rupee a drug to six it's not
much fun still he has to play rupee aid
I think group distance Queen f7 is the
relatively best line okay
yeah rookie six route p7 then Queenie 6
i'm just winning the pony r for nothing
so it's rupee 7 the best move would be
so i guess time morning check okay so
queen bee one is made so are not so not
so easy now Queen a2 is a bit passive
but maybe I have to do that
you know I can't do this I can do this
right check yes it's just a good end
game but I don't have much time check
draw our third count it's so all rights
it's very tricky to try to play for win
here this position I guess g3a3 a stupid
stupid I didn't do that I could have
gone for breakthrough check trying to
play for when this is really risky gras
Arthur I know I'm now I have the drawing
hand check this is a kind of game where
I can easily win on time but I don't
want to gain try take the draw and let's
let's see ya quash just win this but
somehow I didn't didn't manage so what
was the problem r this is winning I have
to do this first
yeah thank you the problem is that here
if you look at them this is the big
difference now I'm coming with this
repealing anti resins directly this is
much much stronger in comparison
attacking this Bishop c4 yeah this is
stronger I was thinking I should win
here anyway but this is remarkably
resilient check okay the computer wants
to do this is much better of course the
computer wants to play this and go for
for this year anyway and now i'm still
attacking is sick so this is very good
for white now that's much better than
what i did really much better check now
in here this is very difficult to do
anything the route with King only six is
locating and I made a very stupid
mistake which she didn't exploit this is
idiotic really we can just take it and
winds just to say it stupid Bishop f4
okay yeah mom this was the draw at the
end probably fair result okay thanks for
watching